Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 51. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie, in der wir so viel über Wissenschaft sprechen.
Und heute wollen wir mal wieder ein wenig ein Metathema angehen, was für Wissenschaftler und nicht nur für Wissenschaftler, sondern insbesondere auch für Studenten sehr interessant sein dürfte.
Nämlich die Frage, wie es eigentlich steht mit der eigenen wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung und dem Potenzial von Gründungen aus einer Hochschule heraus.
Und dazu begrüße ich meine Gesprächspartnerin, Caroline Bock, schönen guten Tag.
Ja guten Tag Herr Pritlove.
Frau Bock wir sind gerade in der TU Darmstadt, Fachbereich Rechts- und Wirtschaftswissenschaften, der sich ein Fachgebiet zugelegt hat namens Gründungsmanagement.
Seit wann gibt es das?
Seit zwei Jahren jetzt, etwas über zwei Jahren.
Okay, und dessen Leiterin Sie sind?
Genau.
Wie kam es denn dazu?
Ja also zu meinem Hintergrund, ich habe ursprünglich internationale BWL studiert an der Uni Erlangen/Nürnberg.
Weil ich mich für ganz verschiedene unterschiedliche Fächer interessiert hatte.
Ganz viele Interessen waren, mich da auch schwer entscheiden konnte, soll es eher in eine technische Richtung gehen, soll es eher in eine rechtliche Richtung gehen oder mathematische und fand dann das Studium der Betriebswirtschaftslehre, sehr viele Fächer kombiniert.
Also man kann in sehr viele Bereiche reingucken, es ist an die Rechtswissenschaften angedockt.
An die Volkswirtschaft, man hat mathematische Grundlagen im Studium.
Man kann sich vertiefen in unterschiedlichste Teilbereiche, auch internationales Management und so weiter.
Und fand das dann sehr spannend.
Was unterscheidet denn das internationale BWL von dem normalen BWL?
Ja von der Struktur des Studiengangs gibt es gewisse Fächer wie Europarecht, internationale Teilfächer, internationales Management und dergleichen, was man belegen musste als Pflichtfächer.
Das gab es im normalen BWL-Studium nicht und ein Aspekt, der wesentlich war, auch dass man verpflichtend ein Jahr auch am Stück im Ausland studieren musste.
Was ich sehr attraktiv fand.
Ich habe mich damals dann entschieden das Ganze an der Uni Lyon in Frankreich zu machen.
Und hatte dort die Möglichkeit, das Doppeldiplom zu erwerben.
Also ich habe das ganz normal, habe die Hälfte meines Hauptstudiums im Diplom in Nürnberg studiert und die andere Hälfte in Frankreich.
Und habe dann von beiden Universitäten den Abschluss bekommen und das war natürlich sehr attraktiv.
Weil wenn man jetzt in Frankreich arbeiten möchte, dann wissen die auch was mit dem Abschluss anzufangen.
Und außerdem war es kulturell sehr bereichernd, persönlichkeitsbildend und das fand ich damals ein sehr ansprechendes Angebot.
Und wie kam es dann zu der Verbindung mit der TU Darmstadt?
Ja das war noch ein bisschen ein längerer Weg.
Ich habe dann im Anschluss an mein Studium an der Uni Erlangen/Nürnberg auch noch promoviert im Bereich betriebswirtschaftliche Steuerlehre.
Das ist das, wo die meisten Menschen fragen, wie kommt dann jetzt noch der Link zu Gründungen?
Ist auch nicht im ersten Augenblick offensichtlich, aber …
Aber über Steuern sollte man schon Bescheid wissen.
Richtig. Also ich kann es nur empfehlen, das ist auch was, was ich auch immer noch in meiner Lehre hochhalte, weil von jetzt finanziellen Aspekten, gerade in den neugegründeten Unternehmen, Ahnung zu haben ist nie verkehrt.
Auch die steuerliche Bewandtnis ist da auch von Vorteil.
Und ich habe mich damals in der Promotion mit der Vorteilhaftigkeit oder der steuerlichen Vorteilhaftigkeit von Finanzierungsinstrumenten beschäftigt, die oft in Gründungsunternehmen, die stark wachsen, eingesetzt werden.
Und so kam dann quasi der Link.
Ich bin dann noch nach der Promotion zur Habilitation an die TU München gegangen.
Habe mich dort wesentlich in Forschung und Lehre mit der Gründungsfinanzierung beschäftigt und von dort wurde ich dann vor zwei Jahren hier an die TU Darmstadt berufen.
Und seitdem bin ich hier und vertrete hier das Fachgebiet für Gründungsmanagement.
Was war denn der Grund, dass die TU Darmstadt sich für die Gründung einer solchen Operation ausgesprochen hat?
Ich glaube der Hintergrund war mit, warum es  überhaupt auch möglich war, ist auch immer die Einrichtung des neuen Fachgebiets eine finanzielle Frage für eine Universität.
Es gibt ja vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium diesen Exist-Wettbewerb.
Exist-4-Wettbewerb für die Gründer oder Gründungshochschulen in Deutschland, wo sich Hochschulen bewerben können, wenn sie explizite Gründungskultur an der Universität fördern möchten.
Auch sich auf die Fahnen schreiben, wir möchten Ausgründungen aus der Hochschule heraus steigern.
Wir möchten eine Gründungskultur etablieren und so weiter.
Und das war ein bundesweit ausgeschriebener Wettbewerb, wo sich auch die TU Darmstadt beworben hatte.
Und dann im Jahr 2013 hier auch erfolgreich eine der 22 Gründerhochschulen dieses Exist-4-Wettbewerbs.
Da gab es auch Vorläufer schon, Vorprogramme.
Und im Rahmen dessen konnte dann massiv ausgebaut werden.
Also es gab vorher auch schon Initiativen, aber ein Gründungszentrum an der Universität als Anlaufstelle für jeden, auch für Gründungsberatungen, alle Fragen, die im Zusammenhang mit Gründungen stehen.
Konnte hier massiv aufgebaut werden oder ausgebaut werden und unter anderem ein Fachgebiet eingerichtet werden.
Aber ich meine war das jetzt sozusagen nur so, ach da ist was im Angebot, da gibt es jetzt Geld, das machen wir jetzt mal oder ging dem Ganzen nicht …
Ich meine wenn man sich dafür bewirbt, dann muss man das ja sozusagen auch ausfüllen.
Da muss man ja auch eine Einstellung dazu haben.
Inwiefern war denn dieses Gründungsthema zu dem Zeitpunkt schon eines?
Es gab sehr viele Initiativen hier schon, die mit Gründungen zusammenhingen oder auch Interessen, wo verschiedene Kollegen sagen, es liegt mir sehr am Herzen oder es gibt auch schon Veranstaltungen, die sich mit dem Thema Ausgründungen oder Gründungen generell beschäftigen.
Das gab es auch schon vor diesem Wettbewerb.
Das ist unter anderem auch was, was sich unser Präsidium auf die Fahne geschrieben hat zu fördern.
Und ja sozusagen als Hochschulleitung da auch dahinter steht, das Ganze sich auf die Fahnen zu schreiben und vorantreiben zu wollen.
Und das war glaube ich mit einer der wesentlichen ausschlaggebenden Gründe, dass man erst mal gesagt hat, man hat auch Interesse, sich an dem Wettbewerb zu beteiligen und natürlich dann sehr froh war, als man da auch eine der geförderten Hochschulen wurde und das Ganze dann auch noch weiter vorantreiben konnte.
Und warum hat man sich das auf die Fahnen geschrieben?
Ich meine das kann einem ja eigentlich auch egal sein.
Ja kann einem egal sein.
Ich glaube das ist schon auch als Universität, man sagt immer, eine der wesentlichen Missionen der Universität ist zum einen Forschung und zum anderen Lehre.
Ich glaube aber, eine dritte Mission ist auch der Transfergedanke.
Dass man sagt, das wissen, das generiert wird an den Universitäten in vielfältiger Form, möchte man auch, zumindest soweit möglich, kommerzialisieren.
Also eine wirtschaftliche Anwendung daraus generieren.
Und das ist schon was, was die TU Darmstadt seit langem praktiziert.
Es gibt ja auch erstens durch die Anknüpfung hier von vielen stark forschenden Unternehmen, aber auch durch viele Institute, Fraunhofer, Helmholtz, in der Nähe mit der eine sehr enge Verknüpfung auch der Universität besteht.
Gibt es sehr große zum einen Interessen auch anwendungsorientiert die Forschung zu betreiben.
Und mehr auch zu schauen, was kann man denn als Transfergedanke in die Gesellschaft hineintragen von dem Wissen, das generiert wird.
Gibt es da Beispiele?
An Ausgründungen oder?
Nein wie dieser Wissenstransfer stattfindet.
Ja, es sind unterschiedliche Formen.
Es kann entweder geschehen über Patente.
Also dass die Universität ein Patent hält und jemand sagt, ich möchte das nutzen, dann kann das über Lizenzierung erfolgen oder auch Transferzahlungen.
Dass eben diese Technologie, die ja eigentlich Eigentum oder intellektuelles Eigentum der Universität ist, genutzt werden kann.
Eine weitere Form ist, dass es eben wirklich eine Ausgründung gibt, dass also entweder Wissenschaftler, Studierende oder ehemalige Mitarbeiter der Universität sagen, wir machen jetzt ein eigenes Unternehmen daraus.
Wir sind auch nicht mehr an der Universität tätig, sondern machen hier was, nutzen vielleicht entweder auch diese Technologie oder die wird irgendwie übertragen in das neue Unternehmen.
Es gibt sogar rechtlich die Möglichkeit für die TU Darmstadt, sich zu beteiligen an einzelnen Ausgründungen, auch als Universität.
Was sehr umstritten ist und auch sehr sehr schwierig im deutschen Kontext das umzusetzen.
Weil natürlich jede öffentliche Universität auch öffentlich gefördert ist.
Und dann zu sagen, wir spielen jetzt Risikokapitalgeber und spielen mal mit dem öffentlich zur Verfügung gestellten Geld und verteilen das in verschiedene Unternehmen, die hoch riskant sind in der Startup-Phase, ist natürlich auch rechtlich gesehen ein Schritt, der abgesichert sein muss und der nicht so leicht umsetzbar ist.
Aber der umsetzbar ist?
Der umsetzbar ist.
Wodurch wird das ermöglicht?
Genau die Details kenne ich nicht.
Jetzt hat natürlich die TU Darmstadt den Vorteil, dass sie eine autonome Hochschule ist, also dass sie viele Dinge selbst entscheiden kann, ohne jetzt darauf angewiesen zu sein, Rücksprache mit dem Landesministerium zu halten in allen Dingen.
Vielleicht wurde das auch dadurch dann initiiert, das weiß ich nicht.
Es ist aber auch eine Möglichkeit, die besteht, die wird aber nicht exzessiv genutzt.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir an 100 Unternehmen direkt als Universität beteiligt sind.
Aber es gibt solche Beteiligungen?
Genau. Und das ist natürlich auch was, wo man auch nachdenken könnte.
Wenn man sagt, es gibt unterschiedliche Stellhebel, wie man das auch noch verankern kann aus rechtlicher und politischer Hinsicht.
Um so eine Gründungskultur zu fördern an Universitäten, ist das zum Beispiel ein Stellhebel, über den man nachdenken könnte.
Das ist so eine Möglichkeit, flächenmäßig und auch leicht und in natürlich festgelegten Rahmenbedingungen möglich ist, aber die möglich gemacht wird.
Und das wäre natürlich ein Aspekt, der hier schon bahnbrechend sein kann.
Ist ja wahrscheinlich eher auch so eine generelle Frage, wie man sich als Universität und Hochschule in dem Zusammenhang aufstellen möchte.
Weil auf der anderen Seite könnte man ja argumentieren, es ist ja eigentlich viel sinnvoller für uns, wenn wir eine starke Forschungsabteilung haben, die permanent zum Beispiel eben Patente erzeugt oder eben andere Kooperationen anstrebt mit anderen Unternehmen, ohne daran jetzt unmittelbar beteiligt zu sein.
Sondern dass man das quasi als Teil des Forschungsbetriebs sieht und damit natürlich auch einen weiteren Einnahmekanal eröffnet und überhaupt den Fokus auf Forschung legt.
Was ja ohnehin kritisiert wird, dass Forschung an den Universitäten nicht mehr so konkurrenzfähig ist mit zum Beispiel Max-Planck, Fraunhofer und anderen privaten Institutionen im wissenschaftlichen Bereich.
Was wäre dann die Motivation für eine tatsächliche Ausgründung, dass sozusagen diese Aktivität außerhalb der Uni stattfindet, man sich aber trotzdem noch daran beteiligt?
Gut die Motivation, sich trotzdem noch dran zu beteiligen ist natürlich bei einer Universität, wenn sie jetzt sagt, das ist intellektuelles Eigentum, was an der Universität generiert wurde, da hat die Universität gewisse Rechte dran, und natürlich auch werden Rückflüsse oder finanzielle Mittel generiert mit diesen Forschungsergebnissen.
Dann ist natürlich auch nur rechtmäßig, wenn die Universität sich diese sichert.
Das ist jetzt möglich auch über Lizenzierung und andere Modelle.
Ein weiteres Modell wäre, dass sich die Uni an diesen Unternehmen beteiligt und sich gar nicht die Patente abkaufen lässt oder die Rechte und dergleichen.
Und da gibt es auch Forschungsergebnisse, auch mehrere Studien, die zugegeben eher aus dem angloamerikanischen Bereich stammen, weil das dort häufiger praktiziert wird und auch häufiger möglich ist, dass sich die Universitäten beteiligen, und man dann eine größere Anzahl an untersuchten Unternehmen haben kann, wo man die Modelle testen kann.
Wo aber auch diese Universitäten größtenteils privat organisiert sind, ohnehin schon.
Ja oder zumindest die Möglichkeit haben, dass sie auf Fonds bestehen, die für solche Investitionen eingesetzt werden dürfen.
Aber hier auch sich zeigt, dass sozusagen langfristig gedacht, also über mehr als 10 Jahre, die finanziellen Rückflüsse für die Universität wesentlich höher und um ein vielfaches höher sind, wenn sie sich über eine Beteiligung am Unternehmen beteiligt, im Gegensatz zu Lizenzierungsmodellen beispielsweise.
Und das ist schon interessant.
Das ist glaube ich was, was in den Köpfen in der deutschen Hochschullandschaft vielleicht ja viel viel Überzeugungsarbeit braucht, bis so was flächendeckend eingesetzt werden kann und dann wirklich auch praktiziert wird.
Und muss auch nicht der Weg sein.
Aber wenn wir vielleicht nochmal einen Schritt zurückgehen, warum sollten Universitäten das machen, Ausgründungen fördern, oder überhaupt eine Gründungskultur fördern, ist es sicher so, dass die Universitäten als eine wesentliche Mission Grundlagenforschung betreiben sollten.
Weil wir erstens glaube ich hier auch in Deutschland gut sind und es auch eine Mission sein muss.
Ein gewisser Bereich, der muss nicht immer gleich anwendbar sein und man muss nicht immer gleich schauen, was kommt denn am Ende dabei rum als Ergebnis.
Sondern viele bahnbrechende Dinge können nur über Grundlagenforschung der Grundstock gelegt werden.
Es gibt aber ja schon ganz natürlich durch sehr viel Zusammenarbeit mit Praxispartnern, durch Kooperationen zwischen Unternehmen und der Universität.
Oder auch allein durch den Anwendungsbezug, den oft Forschungsergebnisse haben, oder Forscher und Wissenschaftler, die an der Universität tätig sind, gibt es schon sehr viele Entwicklungen, die dazu taugen, dass man was ausgründet oder dass man es kommerzialisiert.
Und oft verschwinden viele von diesen Dingen in den Schubladen.
Weil der Wissenschaftler mit der Doktorarbeit fertig ist, dann die Universität verlässt, weil vielleicht niemand sonst direkt die Nachfolge antritt oder ein eigenes anderes Projekt hat, weil der Institutsleiter oder Professor auch nicht die Zeit hat, sich mit einer möglichen Kommerzialisierung von diesen Forschungsergebnissen zu beschäftigen.
Und hier können die Universitäten schon sehr viel Unterstützungsarbeit leisten und das wird auch unter anderem durch dieses BMWI, Exist-4-Projekt gefördert.
Dass es meinetwegen eine Anlaufstelle oder Ressourcen an der Universität gibt, die versuchen, derartige Forschungsergebnisse ausfindig zu machen und auch zu sagen, hey lass es nicht in der Schublade liegen, wir wissen vielleicht auch, ihr könnt euch nicht drum kümmern, aber vielleicht kann sich jemand anderes darum kümmern.
Und es ist auch ganz häufig der Fall, jetzt ist es auch so, nicht jeder ist eine Gründerpersönlichkeit, nicht jeder ist ein Manager eines Unternehmens.
Und vielleicht ist es sogar sehr häufig so, dass der gute Wissenschaftler, die sehr tief in ein Thema einsteigen können, hier vielleicht auch sehr spezialisiert sind oder in ihrem Fachgebiet top Forschungsergebnisse erbringen, vielleicht nicht unbedingt diejenigen sind, die dann rausgehen mit potenziellen Kunden telefonieren.
Dann sagen, wollt ihr das, unsere Anwendung kann folgendes, das braucht ihr unbedingt und wir wollen auch folgendes Geld dafür.
Aber, und das kann eine Universität schon leisten, diese Schnittstelle zwischen meinetwegen der Wirtschaftswelt da draußen und der Universitätsforschungswelt hier, diese Schnittstelle zu forcieren.
Und dann beispielsweise zu sagen, hey ihr als Institut habt ein top Entwicklung gemacht, das ist ganz toll, wir brauchen euch weiter an Bord, um die Forschung voranzutreiben.
Aber wir stellen euch gern Personen zur Seite, die beispielsweise das betriebswirtschaftliche Know-how haben, die den Vertrieb organisieren möchten, die hier jetzt versuchen, diese Schnittstelle in die Wirtschaft hinein oder in die Kommerzialisierung zu bauen.
Also sowohl auch für Forschungsbereiche, die auch innerhalb der Universität verbleiben dort als Forschungsinstitut?
mhm (bejahend).
Also wenn wir von Gründungskultur und Gründung reden, reden wir nicht ausschließlich über Ausgründungen, im Sinne von verlässt die Uni vollständig, sondern es geht generell darum, dem wissenschaftlichen Betrieb quasi noch einen betriebswirtschaftlichen Betrieb beizufügen und an der Stelle zu verstärken?
Genau. Man muss dann aber schauen, wie lässt es sich umsetzen.
Also entweder versucht man das weiter durch eine Kooperation oder dergleichen, an der Uni zu belassen, wirklich fix am Forschungsinstitut.
Oder man versucht dann schon zu sagen, dieses eine Forschungsergebnis nimmt man auch in eine eigene GmbH oder in irgendeine Ausgründung hinein, rechtlich eigenständiges Unternehmen, weil das natürlich dann anders agieren und operieren kann und auch mit wirtschaftlicher Tätigkeit das leichter umsetzbar ist, auch Sachen zu verkaufen, Geld einzunehmen und so weiter, was jetzt in öffentlichen Forschungsinstituten nur begrenzt möglich ist.
Das heißt dieses eine Detail, was wir vorhin angesprochen hatten mit, es gibt auch den Fall, dass es sich zwar um eine Ausgründung handelt, also quasi wirklich eine vollständig rechtlich von der Uni unabhängige Entität entsteht, die Uni aber trotzdem beteiligt ist, dass das quasi auch so ein Zwischenweg sein kann.
Wo man sagt, okay hier in diesem Fall ist es einfach nicht absehbar, dass man diesen Prozess im Rahmen der Uni als Forschungsinstitut etc. unterbringen kann.
Wir wollen es aber auch nicht komplett gehen lassen und eine Verbindung herstellen und dann ist das quasi eine Option, diese Verbindung aufrechtzuerhalten, wenn es auch erst mal nur eine finanzielle ist oder in der auch ein gewisses Mitspracherecht letztlich besteht durch die Beteiligung.
Richtig genau. Oder auch über Lizenzierung und dergleichen, dass da Rückflüsse generiert werden, das geht ja.
Reden wir doch vielleicht nochmal kurz über Gründungskultur an sich, und zwar konkret in Deutschland.
Jetzt ist ja Deutschland ein stark mittelstandsgeprägtes Unternehmen.
Da wird viel vererbt und immer mal wieder gibt es so einzelne, die schießen halt mit so einem neuen Unternehmen hoch.
Aber so, dass wir hier wirklich so gründungsintensiv sind und besonders viel Risiko gehen, ich würde sagen, das gehört nicht unbedingt zum Ruf des Standortes.
Zumindest im Vergleich zu angelsächsischen Bereichen.
Konkret natürlich auch den USA.
Hat sich das geändert?
Ist es vielleicht gar nicht so?
Was ist denn so der Status quo mit dem Wagnis in Deutschland?
Gut, ja jetzt sind wir da, was wir in der Forschung häufig haben, dass ich vielleicht auch eine verzerrte Wahrnehmung habe.
Weil wenn man sich genau mit einem Thema beschäftigt, dann nimmt man natürlich wahr, es gibt doch überall hier Gründungsaktivitäten.
Also ist von mir jetzt auch nur so eine gefühlte Wahrnehmung, vielleicht stimmt die ja auch gar nicht.
Gut, ich glaube schon, dass sich mittlerweile einiges tut.
Jetzt auch wenn ich sehe, jetzt bin ich doch schon über 10 Jahre auch nicht mehr als Student an der Uni, dass sozusagen viele, die studieren, oder die auch mit dem Studium fertig werden, es gibt ja im Prinzip drei Wege, die bleiben entweder in der Wissenschaft nach dem Studium, die gehen in die Industrie oder sie gründen selbst.
Und sozusagen diesen dritten Faktor Gründung auch in die Köpfe zu kriegen bei unseren Absolventen ist eine wesentliche Mission, die ich auch verfolge.
Dass das eine dritte Option ist, die sie gehen können.
Und hier habe ich schon die Wahrnehmung, dass sich in den letzten 10-15 Jahren einiges getan hat.
Dass einige Absolventen mir sagen, ich ziehe diesen Aspekt Gründung auch in Erwägung.
Oder ich kann mir auch vorstellen, selbst zu gründen oder ich habe sogar schon Ideen und möchte das unbedingt umsetzen, aber brauche noch genau, wie finanziere ich denn noch meine Miete und meinen Lebensunterhalt, wie kriege ich das unter einen Hut?
Man sieht jetzt auch durch die Startup-Landschaft Berlin, was ja medial sehr gehypt wird, wo aber dennoch ja auch was dahinter ist, dass dort viele Unternehmen gegründet werden, tut sich hier glaube ich schon was.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir von heute auf morgen zu einer Gründernation werden.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob wir es tatsächlich wirklich irgendwann werden, dass wir uns auf die Fahnen schreiben können, wir sind eine Gründernation.
Aber es zeigt sich jetzt nicht zur Zeit an der Zahl der aktuellen Gründungen, die sind eher rückläufig in den letzten Jahren, der Gesamtanzahl an Gründungen.
Was aber schon zunimmt, zumindest leicht, ist der Anteil an hochinnovativen Gründungen oder auch an Ausgründungen von Akademikern und dergleichen.
Und ich habe schon auch durch die zunehmende Digitalisierung, wo genau viele Kompetenzen, die auch Absolventen von Unis mitbringen, sei es IT-Kenntnisse, Entwicklung von Maschinen oder Vernetzung von unterschiedlichen Maschinen, dass sich hier schon einiges tut.
Wo viele die Chance ergreifen, um zu sagen, jetzt habe ich neben dem Studium so ein bisschen was gemacht, vielleicht auch meine eigene Agentur gehabt und ein bisschen so.
Jetzt versuche ich, das wirklich groß zu machen.
Wenn man vielleicht mal andersrum fragt, was hält denn Leute davon ab, diesen Weg zu gehen?
Eine der wesentlichen Gründe in Deutschland ist glaube sich schon zum einen Arbeitsplatzsicherheit, gerade für Hochschulabsolventen, also es ist so, dass da viele schon ganz normal entweder Angebote haben oder sehr leicht eine Einstellung bekommen, auch zur Zeit durch die konjunkturelle Lage, in etablierten Unternehmen.
Seien es Mittelständler, seien es Großunternehmen.
Und natürlich bringt eine Gründung ein hohes Risiko mit sich.
Jetzt habe ich vielleicht das Angebot aus der Wirtschaft mit einem ganz tollen Jahresgehalt, wo ich ganz problemlos jede Nacht ruhig schlafen kann, auch einen interessanten Job habe.
Und dann zu sagen, nein das mache ich nicht, aber ich versuche jetzt hier mein eigenes Unternehmen hochzuziehen, habe noch keine Ahnung, wer könnte überhaupt Kunde sein, wieviel zahlt der mir, kann ich hier überleben oder sitze ich in drei Monaten auf der Straße?
Das ist natürlich ein wesentlicher Faktor, wo viele sagen bei dieser Entscheidungstendenz, dass sie eher den sicheren Weg gehen und einen sicheren Job in der Industrie nehmen.
Dann glaube ich ist sehr viel kulturell bedingt.
Also es ist so, dass wie Sie sagen, dass es einige Mittelständler gibt, die vielleicht auch mehr oder weniger im persönlichen Umfeld, wo wir sehen, wie so was gehen kann, aber wir sehen nicht unbedingt die direkte Verbindung zu uns.
Also ist nicht unbedingt ein Vorbild, wo wir sagen, ja genauso wie der mache ich das auch und sind ja viele Ähnlichkeiten und Parallelen zu mir und dann mache ich einfach was ähnliches und ziehe das hoch.
Das ist was, was wir wenn dann stärker etablieren müssten, auch diesen Vorbildcharakter, diese Berichte, Einbindung in die Medien, in unsere Ausbildungssysteme, sowohl in der Schule als auch im Ausbildungssystem an den Hochschulen.
Diese Vorbilderfunktion von Gründern, dass die erzählen, wie haben sie es gemacht.
Und man dann sieht, ah da hat er eine ähnliche Entscheidungslage wie ich selbst.
Oder der hatte auch keine Ahnung so richtig am Anfang, wo es hingehen soll, jetzt läuft es ja ganz gut.
Was ganz wichtig ist, was damit zusammenhängt, auch unser, was Sie angedeutet hatten, unsere Einstellung zu Risiko und Unsicherheit.
Also dass jetzt viele Menschen in Deutschland sagen, ja nichts lieber als das, begebe ich mich mal ins Risiko, da gründe ich mal ein Unternehmen, das ist ja nicht unbedingt das erste, wozu viele von uns tendieren.
Ja das scheint so ein Ding zu sein in Deutschland.
Also die Sicherheit ist extrem überbewertet.
Dieses, ja da bin ich jetzt beim Daimler, das hat Wert und das hat ja auch sagen wir mal die gesellschaftliche Anerkennung auch automatisch.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt, oh ich bin jetzt Angestellter.
Da kriegt man ja in der Regel so positiv, oh toll das hast du erreicht und so.
Das ist ja schon was ganz tolles.
Wenn man sagt, ja ich weiß jetzt noch nicht, ob ich in zwei Jahren vielleicht pleite bin oder so und ich probiere halt mal.
Das findet eben nicht dieselbe Anerkennung.
Ist das dann vielleicht auch schon ein Instrument, mit dem man dann Ihre Tätigkeit quasi beginnt?
Dass man schon mal einen anderen Anerkennungskodex auspackt und sagt, ist doch eigentlich was tolles?
Ja ich glaube schon, da fungiert, selbst wenn die USA weit weg sind und kulturell anders sind, aber wenn man jetzt da diese Vorzeigegründe, ob es Steve Jobs, Marc Zuckerberg und dergleichen sind, das ist ja dennoch was, was auch bei uns präsent ist.
Die waren jetzt auch nicht die besten im Studium, vielleicht sogar abgebrochen und haben es dennoch zu was gebracht.
Es gibt natürlich dann Millionen, die auch einen ähnlichen Weg gegangen sind und es nicht dazu gebracht haben.
Ist jetzt auch schwierig zu argumentieren, brich doch einfach dein Studium ab.
Exakt. Das kann ich nicht machen.
Nein würde ich auch gar nicht.
Was hier aber schon entscheidend ist oder sich glaube ich wandelt zur Zeit, wenn ich das richtig beobachte, ist, dass dieses Ansehen von einem guten Angestelltenverhältnis zu einem Gründerdasein sich ein bisschen verschiebt dahingehend, dass ich wahrnehme, dass sich die Präferenzen von Studierenden sich eher verschieben, dass sie sehr viel auch nach Autonomie streben, nach Freiheit.
Also jetzt weiß ich nicht vor 10-15 Jahren konnte man viele vielleicht auch noch locken, wenn man gesagt hat, ja und hier ist on top zu dem fixen und variablen Jahresgehalt auch noch ein Dienstwagen drin und es kann folgendes Modell sein.
Jetzt heutzutage lockt man damit wenige Absolventen.
Die sagen eher, ich hätte lieber für folgendes Carsharing-Portal oder eine BahnCard 100 oder was auch immer.
Was die eher als Anreiz dann auch nehmen, dass sie sagen, ich möchte gern, gibt es nicht ein Modell, dass ich mal ein Jahr Auszeit nehmen kann, auch unbezahlt, aber dafür eben für mich um die Welt reisen oder was auch immer machen.
Dass die dann sagen, ich weiß ich muss dann sehr viel arbeiten in dem Job, ich muss da auch sehr viel bringen und ich möchte das auch gerne und es ist eine interessante Tätigkeit, aber ich lasse mich nur bis zu einer gewissen Schmerzgrenze „ausbeuten“, sondern ich will auch selbst noch leben und diese Work-Live-Balance hochzuheben, steht schon bei vielen sehr sehr hoch mittlerweile.
Und das ist natürlich auch mit einer Tätigkeit als Unternehmensgründer sehr sehr leicht umsetzbar.
Da habe ich meine Freiheit, ich kann entscheiden, wie auch immer mach ich es?
Die meisten arbeiten sehr viel, aber wissen wofür.
Nämlich für die eigene Sache und tun das daher sehr gern, haben aber auch gewisse Freiheiten, wenn die mal ein Freitag bei schönem Wetter es sich zeitlich leisten können und ins Freibad möchten oder wohin auch immer übers Wochenende hin, dann können die das machen.
Hat ja auch gerade so im Punkt Familienplanung dann oft auch nochmal extra Auswirkungen.
Kommen wir nochmal konkret jetzt zu der Arbeit dieses Fach… wie heißt es offiziell? Fachgebiets.
Viel zu allgemein. Dieser Gruppe hier, wie viele Leute sind hier aktiv?
Also in meinem Fachgebiet selbst habe ich einen Vollzeitmitarbeiter.
Wir arbeiten aber sehr eng zusammen mit unserem Gründungszentrum und dort sind nochmal über 10 Mitarbeiter.
Die entweder Gründerberater sind oder Spezialisten hinsichtlich Patentierungen oder Öffentlichkeitsarbeit und solche Aspekte.
Okay das heißt es gibt sowohl ein Gründungszentrum als auch jetzt hier auch nochmal die … wie verhält sich denn das dann zueinander?
Hier ist mehr der rechtliche Aspekt?
Nein nicht unbedingt. Unser Gründungszentrum agiert sehr stark hinein in die Identifikation von Technologiefeldern, Anwendungen von Forschungsergebnissen, die ausgegründet werden können.
Die beraten alle Gründungsinteressierten.
Ja das sind die zwei wesentlichen Aufgaben.
Die schaffen die Vernetzung untereinander, auch mit der lokalen Wirtschaft, mit Unternehmen und so weiter.
Und wir als Fachgebiet beschäftigen uns wesentlich in Forschung und Lehre mit dem Gebiet Unternehmungsgründungen und tragen das in der Lehre in die Uni hinein, in die unterschiedlichen anderen Fachbereiche, die wir hier an der Uni haben.
Also wir sind zwar offiziell am Fachbereich Rechts- und Wirtschaftswissenschaften angesiedelt, aber gerade an der technischen Uni kommen ganz viele Entwicklungen, die zu Gründungen führen, natürlich aus den unterschiedlichsten Fakultäten.
Und unterschiedlichsten Fachrichtungen.
Und deshalb ist unsere Lehre auch so angesiedelt, dass sie im Prinzip von jedem Studierenden der Universität belegt werden kann.
Sei es als Wahlfach. Wir arbeiten auch sehr stark da rein, dass es kurrikular eingebunden werden kann in die Studiengänge.
Dass also die Studierenden nicht nur die Veranstaltungen hören und sagen, ja will ich, weil ich dran interessiert bin.
Sondern die auch sozusagen kreditiert bekommen im Rahmen ihres Studiums.
Und da auch eine Prüfung ablegen und dann ganz normal die einbringen können.
Das heißt das Gründungszentrum kümmert sich um sehr viel Technikalitäten.
Beobachtet sagen wir mal auch die Forschung, die konkret betreiben wird in der Schule.
Gibt dann vielleicht auch erste Impulse und ist so ein technischer Dienstleister, sage ich mal salopp?
Während Ihr Fachbereich versucht, das Wissen über Gründung konkret mit in die Lehre und auch in die Forschung mit einfließen zu lassen.
Quasi als begleitender Wissensanteil anderer Studiengänge?
Welche Studiengänge betrifft denn das?
Ist das grundsätzlich für alle Studiengänge offen?
mhm (bejahend). Also es ist grundsätzlich für alle Studiengänge offen ja.
Es kann bei vielen Studiengängen – wir haben so einen Anteil Studium Generale oder auch Wahlfächer, wo meine Vorlesungen und Fächer eingebracht werden können.
Und wir arbeiten sehr stark daran, dass beispielsweise ein Schwerpunkt Innovationen und Entrepreneurship, dass hier ganz viele Veranstaltungen wirklich auch als Schwerpunkt Wahlthema in den unterschiedlichsten Studiengängen eingebracht werden können.
Also die Studenten können dann durchaus sage ich mal 10-20% ihres gesamten Studiums als Wahlfach auf Entrepreneurship in Innovation legen.
Auch wenn sie Informatik studieren, Maschinenbau, Chemie oder andere Fächer.
Eben weil wir gesehen haben, dass das – und das ist auch ein wesentlicher Erkenntnisprozess mittlerweile – dass diese Verankerung – nicht nur jetzt für Wirtschaftswissenschaftler – wichtig ist, sondern gerade für alle möglichen Studierenden.
Dass die sagen können, entweder habe ich so eine Idee oder ich weiß zwar nicht genau, was damit zusammenhängt, das interessiert mich aber, und ich möchte Kompetenzen in dem Bereich Gründungen und Innovation aufbauen.
Wie hat sich so die Nachfrage nach diesem Fachgebiet entwickelt in den letzten zwei Jahren?
Sehr gut. Also ich hatte im ersten, als ich im Oktober kam, auch in dem Oktober im Semester glaube ich so ungefähr 70 Teilnehmer.
Was jetzt auch nicht schlecht ist in meiner Grundlagenveranstaltung.
Als die heißt Grundlagen des Entrepreneurship.
Wenn man ganz neu ist und noch unbekannt.
Wir hatten dann im zweiten Jahr, als wir es angeboten haben, schon 250 Teilnehmer.
Also das war wirklich ein massives Wachstum, wo wir dann auch Raumwechsel und alles machen mussten, weil wir mit dem Ansturm doch nicht gerechnet hatten.
Ja was sehr sehr positiv ist.
Und das sind wirklich, deswegen ist die Veranstaltung auch sehr spannend, aus allen möglichen Studienrichtungen.
Also da sitzen Sportwissenschaftler drin, Informatiker, Maschinenbauer, Philosophiestudenten, Psychologiestudenten.
Und das schafft natürlich auch … die müssen dann auch teilweise, obwohl es eine relativ große Veranstaltung ist, in kleinen Gruppen zusammenarbeiten.
Was natürlich allein durch die Vielfalt an Studiengängen sehr interdisziplinär ist.
Und das ist glaube ich zum einen für die Studierenden toll, mal über den Tellerrand blicken, mit jemandem zusammenarbeiten müssen, der eine andere Denkweise hat, vielleicht auch eine andere Fachrichtung.
Ja und dadurch findet schon auch ein guter Austausch statt und auch eine Vernetzung innerhalb der Universität.
Bei 26.000 und paar zerquetschte Studenten hier an der Uni ist es ja immerhin schon 1%, die sich quasi aktiv dann diesen Fachbereich noch mit dazu wählen.
Ja.
Finde ich ja eigentlich schon eine ganz ordentliche Zahl.
Und das nur … die haben ja normalerweise eine Studiendauer von 5 Jahren. Also genau muss man über die Studienzeit hinweg vielleicht sogar mehr, oder könnte die Zahl auch höher liegen.
Ja. Nochmal vielleicht zu der Verteidigung.
Also gibt es Studiengänge, wo das Interesse besonders groß ist?
Ja, viele Informatikstudiengänge haben sehr großes Interesse.
Maschinenbauer, Elektrotechniker.
Gut das sind auch sehr starke Studenten oder Studierenden zahlenmäßig sehr starke Studiengänge hier.
Aber es gibt auch in den Sportwissenschaften sehr viel Interesse.
Also bei der Informatik kann ich mir das sehr gut vorstellen, dass das sozusagen …
Also einerseits weil natürlich das Digitale natürlich ein heißes Thema ist im Gründungsbereich.
Andererseits kenn ich auch aus eigener Anschauung die Unfähigkeit zur Betriebswirtschaftslehre ist im informatischen Bereich immer sehr verbreitet gewesen.
Über Maschinenbauer kann ich jetzt nicht so viel sagen.
Aber ist natürlich schon so, wenn man sich extrem mit so einem Feld beschäftigt, wo eigentlich ja zunächst einmal wirtschaftliche Größenordnungen nahezu keine Rolle spielen, dass es dann sehr schwierig ist, sich so mit den Zwängen und Realitäten des Wirtschaftslebens auseinanderzusetzen.
Bis hin zu so einer Unwilligkeit, Unfähigkeit, je nachdem mag bei jedem so und so sein.
Insofern ist das ja eigentlich ein sehr schönes Zeichen, dass Studenten sich dann quasi aufstellen und sagen, nein die offene Flanke möchte ich gar nicht haben, und jetzt besser mal schließen und tu mir mal dann dieses Fachgebiet auch noch mit rein.
Mit welchen Erwartungshaltungen kommen denn die Studenten rein?
Ja, das ist auch ganz unterschiedlich.
Ich frage auch ab quasi per Handzeichen, wer hat schon gegründet?
Das sind meist jetzt auch von den 200 Leuten eine Hand voll.
Also dass viele dabei sind, halt viele, die neben dem Studium was kleines machen.
Aber immerhin das ist ja auch …
Die schon mal angefangen haben und jetzt wissen wollen, ob sie es auch richtig gemacht haben?
Richtig. Dann gibt es sehr viele Gründungsinteressierte.
Die sich vorstellen können, würde ich mal sagen, das sind so 40%, die sich vorstellen können, ein eigenes Unternehmen zu gründen und deshalb diesen Schwerpunkt auch mit wählen.
Die anderen, warum auch immer, das müsste ich dann genauer ergründen, da habe ich erstens nicht so viel Zeit und müsste es vielleicht auch anders abfragen, mit unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten, die hier bestehen.
Ob die das machen, weil es Credits dafür gibt oder weil es von der Zeit her die Vorlesung günstig liegt, das wag ich nicht zu mutmaßen.
Aber was auch ist, die müssen gar nicht … das sage ich auch in meiner Vorlesung, die behandelt die Grundlagen des Entrepreneurship, aber es ist eine wissenschaftlich basierte Vorlesung.
Also hier behandeln wir unterschiedlichste Aspekte, die mit einer Unternehmensgründung zusammenhängen von der Teamzusammensetzung idealerweise bis hin zu finanziellen Buchführungsaspekten, die wichtig sind.
Marketinggrundlagen, Strategiegrundlagen im Umgang mit Wachstum.
Internationalisierung, aber auch unternehmerisches Scheitern und solche Fragen.
Also eine sehr große Bandbreite.
Wir können nicht bei jedem Aspekt logischerweise bei einer Vorlesung ins Detail.
Und es ist auch eine wissenschaftlich basierte Vorlesung, das heißt hier behandeln wir auch die Ergebnisse von Studien und die Erkenntnisse, die bislang aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht auf dem Gebiet gewonnen wurden.
Es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Vorlesung, die ein Rezeptbuch an die Hand gibt am Ende, wenn die Studenten die Prüfung geschrieben haben, was sie machen müssen, um erfolgreich zu gründen.
Das sage ich denen auch ganz offen zu Beginn.
Und da gibt es auch noch andere Veranstaltungen, die ich anbiete, die da expliziter darauf eingehen.
Oder dann in Zusammenarbeit mit unserem Gründungszentrum, die bieten auch sehr viele Veranstaltungen an, wo dann eher auch – und das kann jeder Studierende hier aus der TU Darmstadt und jeder Absolvent – kann sich an unser Gründungszentrum wenden und bekommt hier wirklich eine Gründungsberatung ganz individuell für eine Idee meinetwegen zur Verfügung gestellt.
Und auch kostenfrei für ihn angeboten, wo er sich gezielt auch für die eigene Idee Hilfestellung holen kann.
Und das auch nach einem sehr vorgefertigten Schema, das möglichst objektiviert die Beratung sicherstellt auf einem gewissen Qualitätsniveau.
Also zum Beispiel wenn ich jetzt im Maschinenbau tätig bin und da irgendwie mich mit Lasern spezialisiere, könnte man mal hingehen und sagen, gibt es da vielleicht eine Marktlücke, gibt es da Verbindungen auch zu anderen Unternehmen, die schon im Dunstkreis der Universität unterwegs sind?
So die Richtung?
Genau, zum Beispiel. Oder Entwicklungen oder ich möchte das weiter vorantreiben, könnt ihr mir helfen?
Ich habe schon gesehen, das gibt es, dann vielleicht in einem Unternehmen in den USA, aber die machen einen anderen Bereich oder wie auch immer.
Und ich möchte das jetzt vorantreiben, könnt ihr mir dabei helfen?
Ich brauche auch wie auch immer finanzielle Mittel, wir sind aber schon ein Team, wir haben folgende Kompetenzen und dann setzen die sich mit einem zusammen.
Also wir haben es jetzt hier quasi mit einer Wissenschaft des Gründungsmanagements zu tun.
Das klingt ja recht neu. Also wie weit ist denn dieses Feld überhaupt greifbar?
Inwiefern agieren denn andere, die tatsächlich dort interessante Studien bringen unter diesem Begriff, ist das schon so ein etabliertes Thema oder findet sich das gerade noch?
Und was für Erkenntnisse bringt denn die Forschung?
Ja, also es ist eine sehr sehr junge, in der relativ jungen Wissenschaft jetzt auch der Wirtschaftswissenschaften, ist der Bereich Entrepreneurship oder auch Gründungsmanagement ein sehr sehr junger Bereich.
Ich glaube auch die erste Professur im deutschsprachigen Raum wurde entweder 1995 oder 1998 eingerichtet.
Also noch nicht vor sehr langer Zeit.
Und mittlerweile gibt es aber an den deutschen Unis und Hochschulen über 135 Lehrstühle.
Also man sieht auch in dieser kurzen Zeitspanne wurde dieses Themengebiet massiv ausgebaut an den Hochschulen.
Die auch alle unter dem Begriff Gründungsmanagement laufen?
Nein das ist Entrepreneurship, das heißt dann manchmal vielleicht auch Technologie-/Innovationsmanagement und Unternehmensgründung oder Startup-Management.
Okay also gibt da noch keinen definierten Brand, unter dem sich jetzt alle versammeln?
Nein ich würde sagen, der definierteste Brand ist schon Entrepreneurship.
Deswegen heißt meine Vorlesung beispielsweise auch Grundlagen des Entrepreneurship …
Aber das ist funktional äquivalent zu dem Begriff Gründungsmanagement?
Wenn man es Wort für Wort übersetzt vermutlich nicht, aber es ist das gemeint.
Das ist gemeint, genau okay.
Das ist schon die Disziplin, in der ich angesiedelt bin.
Ich finde das in gewisser Hinsicht nachvollziehbarer Gründungsmanagement.
Weil das ist zwar immer noch so eine merkwürdige Sprachvermischung, aber … macht es irgendwie relativ klar, worum es geht.
Genau, und das ist eine sehr junge Disziplin und hier gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze.
Also es geht immer um den Bereich etwas zu gründen, etwas neu zu schaffen.
Und es gibt hier ganz unterschiedliche Teilbereiche.
Also welche, in dem ich auch viel mache, den Bereich Gründungsfinanzierung oder Entrepreneurial Finance, wo es darum geht, wenn diese Unternehmen wachsen möchten, woher bekommen die Geld?
Dann gibt es natürlich was, wo es mit dem Verhalten von Gründern zu tun hat.
Oder der Teamzusammensetzung, was sind hier Probleme, die auftreten, was sind typischerweise Rollen, die in Gründerteams auftreten?
Welche Eigenschaften sollten Gründerteams idealerweise aufweisen?
Welche Teams sind erfolgreicher als andere?
Was sind auch sozusagen die Schwierigkeiten oder die Grundlagen von jungen Unternehmen und wie wirkt sich das auf deren Erfolg aus?
Also wir sprechen da immer von dieser ressourcenorientierten oder Ressource based view.
Jedes Unternehmen und ein junges Unternehmen hat andere Ressourcen oder eine Ressourcenbasis, die zur Verfügung gestellt hat.
Es ist meinetwegen die Technologie, die Mitarbeiter, das Team, also die Human Ressources, das ist Kapital und vielleicht darüber auch noch soziale Ressourcen, das Netzwerk, verschiedene Akteure, mit denen man Kooperationen eingehen kann.
Und hier kann man natürlich sagen, je nachdem wie diese genutzt werden, diese Ressourcen, ergibt sich ein unternehmerischer Erfolg.
Und es kann sich durchaus bei etablierten Unternehmen entscheiden oder unterscheiden von neugegründeten Unternehmen.
Weil ein Gründer vielleicht nicht 100.000 Mitarbeiter hat, sondern nur das Gründerteam von vielleicht 3-4 Personen, vielleicht zwei Praktikanten und dann nochmal zwei Festangestellte und wächst dann aber vielleicht schnell.
Auch das Wachstum von Unternehmen, die Internationalisierungstendenzen oder Internationalisierungsbemühungen sind vielleicht anders bei etablierten Unternehmen als bei jungen Unternehmen.
Das sind viele Fragestellungen. Oder auch unternehmerisches Scheitern ist natürlich sehr relevant bei neugegründeten Unternehmen, weil sehr viele scheitern.
Aber das zu analysieren, warum ist das der Fall?
Was sind die Hauptgründe? Wie könnten die vielleicht ausgemerzt werden?
Dass es nicht zum Scheitern kommt. Das sind so wesentliche Faktoren da.
Bzw. wenn es zum Scheitern kommt, dass es nicht so schlimm ist, dass es zum Scheitern kommt?
Zum Beispiel auch richtig.
Also was liefert denn da die Forschung sozusagen?
Also was sind denn so die Erkenntnisse durch Studien und andere Forschungstätigkeit in diesem Bereich, die einen hier voranbringen?
Was weiß man denn jetzt, was man vor fünf Jahren noch nicht wusste?
Vor fünf Jahren?
Oder irgendein anderer beliebiger Zeitraum, in dem sich das jetzt nennenswert abgebildet hat?
Ja, was man schon sehr … es ist unterschiedlich, wenn wir beispielsweise die Rahmenbedingungen ansehen, auch in gesellschaftlicher, politischer und kultureller Hinsicht.
Macht sehr viel aus eine etablierte Gründungskultur.
Entweder generell in der Wirtschaft oder auch in der Gesellschaft, dass man sieht, man zieht es in Erwägung, überhaupt zu gründen, das fördert natürlich Gründungsaktivitäten.
Aber auch was dazu führen kann, das zu stimulieren und eine Art Startup-Kultur, Gründungskultur zu schaffen in der Gesellschaft.
Und da gibt es politische Stellhebel, das ist nochmal ein eigener Punkt für sich.
Aber auch eben kulturelle, wo das gefördert wird, dass man sagt, man trägt das schon in die Ausbildung rein, meinetwegen auch schon in Schulen.
In die universitäre Ausbildung, dass man sagt, wir kommen überhaupt irgendwann mal in Kontakt mit dem Thema und können es dann für uns auch in Erwägung ziehen.
Sonst berühren wir das vielleicht im ganzen Studium nie oder auch in unserem Ausbildungsleben kommen wir da gar nie drauf.
Das ist ein wesentlicher Aspekt.
Ein weiterer ist, dass schon auch diese Teamzusammensetzungen sehr entscheidend sein können und auch die …
Also dass beispielsweise wenn die Kompetenzen im Gründungsteam relativ heterogen sind, also sich gut ergänzen.
Wenn ich jemanden habe, der sich eher um die Entwicklung kümmert, jemanden, der sich eher um den Vertrieb kümmert, jemanden, der sagt, ich kümmere mich dann darum, dass wir das Wachstum stemmen oder die Kooperation mit anderen Partnern abzustimmen.
Also das ist einer der Erfolgsfaktoren.
Das klingt nach einer relativ einfachen Erkenntnis.
Ja.
Wo ich mich jetzt gerade frage, brauche ich da einen wissenschaftlichen Studiengang dafür, um darauf zu kommen?
Oder sehe ich das jetzt ein bisschen zu einfach?
Nein, ist durchaus berechtigt.
Es ist so, dass wir natürlich da genauer in Details gehen können, dass es dann auch Studien gibt, die sagen, wenn es hochkomplex ist die technologische Anwendung, dann ist es sogar besser, wenn die Kompetenzen im Team der Kerngründer nicht so heterogen sind.
Weil sie sich sonst verzetteln oder weil vielleicht derjenige, der den Vertrieb macht, gar keine Ahnung hat, was er da eigentlich verkauft, weil er zu wenig technisches Know-how hat.
Und das ist zum Beispiel schon eine Erkenntnis.
Also bis vor kurzem war es auch eine sehr breite Erkenntnisse, dass je heterogener ein Team ist quasi, desto besser ist es gewappnet dafür, die Gründung erfolgreich zu machen.
Und da kommt man etwas davon ab oder neuere Forschungserkenntnisse deuten auch darauf hin, wenn das technologisch hochkomplex ist, so richtige Hochtechnologiegründungen, dass es teilweise auch gut ist, wenn die nicht so heterogen sind die Gründungsteams.
Oder auch ja im Bereich der unterschiedlichen politischen Stellhebel, was kann man tun, um Gründungen zu fördern?
Oder ein Ökosystem zu schaffen, in dem Gründer erfolgreich sind?
Ja sind es die rechtlichen Gegebenheiten, ist es die Patentpolitik, sind es steuerliche Gesetzgebungen, die hier entscheidend sind?
Und hier kann man schon sehr interessante Erkenntnisse auch gewinnen, die dann konkret auch in eine politische Umsetzbarkeit oder hier Hinweise geben für eine politische Umsetzbarkeit, um eine Gründungskultur zu fördern.
Jetzt dreht sich ja eine ganze Menge um dieses Thema, wir haben es ja jetzt schon beleuchtet.
Entrepreneurship ist ein breites Feld.
Sie waren ja auch an der Gründung wiederum einer solchen Gründungsakademie beschäftigt.
Das wird jetzt hier sehr meta.
Konkret dem Social Entrepreneurship Akademie in München, an der vier verschiedene Universitäten beteiligt sind.
Neben dem ganzen Unternehmertum findet ja gerade dieses soziale Unternehmertum derzeit an manchen Stellen nochmal eine besondere Bedeutung.
Was unterscheidet diese sozialen Unternehmerlinien von dem vielleicht normalen Ansatz?
Was hat Sie motiviert, da auch noch mit hinein zu gründen?
Welche Rolle spielt das?
Ja das ist ein ganz interessanter Ansatz.
Es ist ja oft so, dass ein Kriterium, selbst jetzt in steuerrechtlicher Hinsicht gilt ja ein Unternehmer als Unternehmen, wenn es als Hauptziel eine Gewinnerzielung hat.
Das sich in finanziellem Gewinn äußert in der Regel.
Das ist bei Sozial Entrepreneur oder sozialen Unternehmen nicht unbedingt so.
Sondern die verfolgen oft ja einen gesellschaftlichen Mehrwert durch einen unternehmerischen Ansatz.
Also da ist es die Beseitigung von einem gesellschaftlichen Missstand oder gesellschaftlichen Problemen, aber nicht durch reine Fördergelder und Verteilung mit der Gießkanne oder wie auch immer durch reine Zuwendung.
Sondern es steckt immer ein unternehmerischer Ansatz dahinter.
Das ist mehr oder weniger auf populär geworden durch Mohammad Yunus, der ja dann auch den Friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat dafür, dass er Mikrokredite an die ärmere Bevölkerung vergab.
Und wo von vielen etablierten Banken oder auch Wirtschaftsvertretern gesagt wurde, ja wie kann man das machen?
An die arme Bevölkerung finanzielle Mittel vergeben, das tun wir eben gerade nicht oder haben auch Vorschriften, die uns das verbieten als Banken, weil die Ausfallrisiken und Ausfallraten hier besonders hoch sein werden.
Und Mohammad Yunus ist im Prinzip dennoch diesen Weg gegangen und hat gesagt, ich gebe auch armen Menschen Kredite, damit sie sich eine Art Unternehmen aufbauen können.
Also meinetwegen dass sie auch auf den Markt gehen können und Waren verkaufen können, aber die Waren natürlich erst mal mit einem Kredit einkaufen müssen.
Und so hat sich das dann gezeigt, dass ja die ganzen Kritiker Unrecht gestraft wurden, weil die Ausfallrisiken waren extrem gering.
Er hat fast immer das Geld wiederbekommen und hat dann auch gezeigt, dass er dadurch auch wirklich nachhaltig es schaffen konnte, dass das Überleben der armen Bevölkerung gesichert oder auch wesentlich verbessert wurde, weil sie jetzt sogar eigenes Einkommen generiert haben und nicht mehr auf andere Formen der Unterstützung angewiesen waren.
Und vor allem, wenn ich es richtig erinnere, insbesondere Frauen an der Stelle nochmal einen besonderen Bonus geliefert haben.
Ja richtig exakt.
Die dann ein eigenes Geschäft haben, Waren verkauft haben oder selbst hergestellt haben.
Die ja wiederum verkauft haben und dadurch Einnahmen erzielt haben und es dann ja so …
Und damit sozusagen überhaupt auch erst mal einen Weg in ein Unternehmertum geboten haben, was sich sonst so unter den sozialen Umständen wahrscheinlich gar nicht eröffnet hätte.
Exakt.
Also konkret war das ja mit Schwerpunkt in Indien, wenn ich es richtig erinnere.
Genau.
Da ist es für Frauen jetzt nicht so einfach, ist es auch sonst nicht, aber dort nochmal besonders.
Und wie kann man das bewerten?
Also ich meine, wenn das normale Unternehmertum nach Umsatz und Gewinn abgerechnet wird, ist es natürlich mit sozialem Unternehmertum nicht so ohne weiteres.
Weil man kann ja nicht sagen, hier guck mal, so viel Gewinn hat die Gesellschaft gemacht, lässt sich ja in Euro schwer gegenrechnen.
Richtig. Vor allem weil es ja unterschiedliche Arten gibt, das dann gegen zu bewerten, braucht man die jetzt nicht mehr unterstützen und rechnet entgegen, was man denen als Unterstützung hätte zukommen lassen oder man sagt, es ist ja dennoch eine Art meist unternehmerischer Ansatz dahinter, der vielleicht ein bisschen Gewinn oder Rendite abwirft, wie misst man das jetzt dann?
Das kann man aber so nicht aufrechnen, das ist sehr schwer, das zu bewerten.
Es gibt aber auch hier Ansätze, die versuchen das zu tun.
Und da hat auch eine ehemalige Kollegin von mir an der TU München, Barbara Scheck, hat einen social reporting Standard in ihrer Dissertation entwickelt, der auf verschiedene oder eine Methodik aufzeigt, wie man derartige gesellschaftliche Verbesserungen, politische Verbesserungen, Verbesserung von sozialen Missständen auch bewerten kann und so einen gesellschaftlichen Impact hat.
Also dann wirklich auch, was ist ein messbarer Wert für dieses social Entrepreneur Unternehmen, was ist hier ein Mehrwert, der geschaffen wird auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise und wie kann man den darstellen, abbilden, messbar machen?
Auch durch unterschiedliche Größen und die vielleicht auch vergleichbar machen.
Und es ist insofern auch eine sehr interessante Initiative, die immer wieder Wellen schlägt, aber meiner Ansicht nach noch nicht weit genug.
Weil immer noch zum Beispiel bei der Vergabe von öffentlichen Mitteln oder Fördermitteln auch an soziale Institutionen oder auch soziale Unternehmer oft derartige Kriterien oder auch eine Vergleichbarkeit oder eine Art von Impactmessung oft gar keine Rolle spielt.
Sondern das wird vergeben nach welchen Kriterien auch immer, aber nicht unbedingt nach messbaren Größen, die natürlich auch abzielen auf solche Beseitigungen von sozialen Missständen oder dergleichen.
Und da könnte man schon eher versuchen, das auch zu vereinheitlichen, auch zwischen unterschiedlichsten Ansätzen im sozialen Bereich und hier stärker auf so eine Art Standard abzustellen.
Spielt das hier eine Rolle in Ihrer Lehre?
Es spielt eine Rolle, derzeit keine große, weil die Hauptansätze, die wir derzeit in der Lehre machen, nicht mit social Entrepreneurship zusammenhängen, sondern dadurch auch, dass ich an einer technischen Universitäten bin, sehr viel eher mit konkreten Anwendungsfällen, die aus der Technik oder auch den Ingenieurwissenschaften, Naturwissenschaften kommen.
Trotzdem macht es so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als müsste Ihr Feld eigentlich auch einen erhöhten interdisziplinären Bedarf haben.
Steht man hier in Verbindung mit anderen Fachbereichen der Universität oder anderer Universitäten?
Ich meine wenn wir über Teams reden, dann habe ich gleich die Psychologie im Hintergrund etc., ist das so?
Ja das ist so. Also zum einen dadurch, dass meine Lehre auch in viele andere Studiengänge eingebunden ist, sind wir hier im Austausch mit vielen anderen Fakultäten.
Ist auch so dadurch, dass viele Entwicklungen oder Gründungsideen aus anderen Fachrichtungen kommen, bin ich hier auch im Austausch mit Kollegen und auch innerhalb verschiedener Unis ist man dann auch teilweise durch Anknüpfungen und dergleichen gut vernetzt.
Also das ist auch was, was jetzt an meinem Fachgebiet sehr sehr spannend ist, dass man immer wieder Einblick, wenn auch nicht besonders tief, aber Einblick in ganz unterschiedliche neue technologische Entwicklungen erhält.
Hier sich auch gut austauschen kann, auch natürlich ganz vielfältige Erfahrungen macht durch diese unterschiedlichen interdisziplinären Verknüpfungen.
Das ist super spannend finde ich.
Es wird sicherlich auch passende Konferenzen und ähnliche Ereignisse geben, die jetzt hier relevant sind.
Gibt es da irgendwas, was man erwähnen sollte?
Ja, also im deutschsprachigen Raum sehr relevant ist, ist das sogenannte G-Forum.
Die interdisziplinäre Jahreskonferenz der Gründungs- oder des Förderkreises Gründungsforschung.
Das ist ein Verein hier auch im deutschsprachigen Raum und hier findet auch ein reger Austausch statt von vielen Forschern, die sich im deutschsprachigen Raum vor allem mit dem Bereich Gründungsforschung beschäftigen.
Aber genauso gut mit vielen, die in der Innovationsforschung tätig sind, auch mit Praxis oder Praktikern, die hier in dem Feld agieren.
Sei es als Förderer, sei es weil sie sich interessieren, sei es als Unternehmen, weil sie hier in dem Bereich sehr innovativ sein möchten oder auch eine Förderung von Gründungsunternehmen sich gerne damit beschäftigen.
Werden wir doch nochmal ein bisschen praktisch zum Abschluss.
Wenn ich jetzt hier studieren würde, irgendein Feld, vorhin habe ich Maschinenbau genannt, bleiben wir einfach mal dabei, letztlich auch egal, ich denke mir erst mal nichts böses und studiere hier so vor mich hin.
Angenommen ich komme jetzt selber noch nicht so auf die Idee, was gibt es hier für Incentives, was werden hier für Maßnahmen seitens entweder dieses Studiengangs oder vielleicht auch des Gründerzentrums oder der Uni an sich genommen, um sozusagen Studierende auch überhaupt erst mal auf diesen Pfad zu bringen?
Überhaupt erst mal so diese Vorstellung in den Kopf zu bekommen mit, ja du kannst jetzt hier nicht nur eine Wissensauskunftei und Dienstleister werden, sondern du hast vielleicht auch die Berufung selber ein Business zu schaffen, was eigentlich deinen eigenen Fähigkeiten mehr entgegenkommt.
Weil ich denke, und das ist ja auch nochmal so ein kleiner Nebenaspekt, den ich auch so aus der eigenen selbständigen Arbeit heraus kenne.
Man kann sich ja im Prinzip, wenn man so diese Freiheit der eigenen wirtschaftlichen Entfaltung hat, man kann sich ja sozusagen auch seinen Beruf so zusammenzimmern, wie man ihn braucht.
Einerseits von dem technischen Interesse her, andererseits auch sagen wir mal von der Ausgestaltung der konkreten zeitlichen und inhaltlichen Ausgestaltung der Tätigkeit, das ist ja durchaus attraktiv.
Aber wie erreicht man Leute überhaupt oder was für Maßnahmen werden jetzt hier konkret unternommen, um Studierende überhaupt erst mal in Berührung zu bringen mit dieser Vorstellung?
Hier ist es ganz wichtig, oder hier machen wir zum Beispiel was oder eine Sache, die entscheidend ist, jetzt kann ich nicht, ich bin nicht in jedem Studiengang direkt in den Fachveranstaltungen vertreten.
Als der Maschinenbauer, wenn er nicht will, kann er gut um mich herumkommen.
Es ist aber so, dass ganz viele meiner Kollegen schon Initiativen oder auch Veranstaltungen haben, die das Thema Gründungen beleuchten, was ich auch sehr interessant fand, als ich hierher kam, dass das nicht, obwohl es ja ein neu geschaffenes Fachgebiet war, nicht so war, dass es hier nur eine grüne Wiese gab und ich alles aufbauen musste.
Sondern es gab schon sehr sehr viele Kollegen, die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigen.
Und das ist auch eine der entscheidenden Sachen, was wir auch versuchen zu forcieren, das jetzt verschiedene Kollegen, die in den unterschiedlichsten Studiengängen in den fachspezifischen Veranstaltungen tätig sind, dass die auch schon mal hinweisen oder dieses Thema Gründungen aufgreifen in ihren Veranstaltungen.
Jemand es dann spannend findet und sagt, ach das möchte ich vertiefen und dann vielleicht weitere Veranstaltungen wählt.
Zum anderen haben wir natürlich unterschiedliche Initiativen, unser Gründungszentrum Highest an der TU Darmstadt hat zum Beispiel auch einen Gründerstammtisch oder hat unterschiedliche Veranstaltungen.
Eins davon ist auch ein ganz zwangloser Gründerstammtisch, der in regelmäßigen Abständen, was auch bekannt gegeben wird auf der Homepage, stattfindet in der Kneipe hier in Darmstadt.
Wo Gründer hingehen und sich austauschen, aber ganz zwanglos beim Bierchen am Abend.
Und wenn jemand Interesse hat, kann er sagen, ah da setze ich mich einfach mal dazu.
Ich höre vielleicht beim ersten Mal nur hin, finde ich vielleicht spannend, geh beim nächsten Mal wieder hin oder sowas.
Dann haben wir auch einen Ideenwettbewerb ausgeschrieben, der einmal im Jahr läuft.
Den wir jetzt ja glaube ich seit 5-6 Jahren durchführen, und der sehr regen Zuspruch findet.
Wir haben auch im letzten Jahr das erste Mal auch sozusagen alle Preise auf zwei unterschiedlichen Kategorien ausgeschrieben.
Also einen für Studierende, studentische Ideen, und einen für Ideen von wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeitern.
Und es ist auch ganz bewusst als Ideenwettbewerb ausgeschrieben.
Es müssen keine tatsächlichen Gründungsideen sein, es müssen auch nicht schon gegründete Unternehmen sein hier von Studierenden oder Mitarbeitern.
Sondern wer eine Idee hat und sagt, ich habe eine Entdeckung gemacht oder ich habe da was im Kopf und das würde ich gern ausarbeiten, kann dieses Konzept einreichen und nimmt an diesem Ideenwettbewerb teil.
Und er hat auch über diese Zeit hinweg massiven Zulauf gefunden.
Jetzt von der Anzahl der eingereichten Ideen kann ich es nicht aus dem Kopf sagen, aber allein die Teilnehmerzahl, also auch die Zuhörer natürlich, war im letzten Jahr bei über 1000 und ich glaube im Jahr davor bei ca. 500.
Und so ist das wirklich massiv auch angewachsen.
Was eine enorme Veranstaltung ist, die dann natürlich auch Tragkraft hat und Bekanntheit innerhalb der Universität.
1000?
Teilnehmer an der Abschlussveranstaltung, wo auch die Preise prämiert wurden, und sich dann die Ideen oder die Gewinnerideen kurz präsentieren dürfen.
Und so was fördert natürlich auch den Gründergedanken.
Wir versuchen, da haben wir sicher auch noch einiges an Arbeit zu leisten, was immer ganz sinnvoll ist an der Uni, dass es eine Institution gibt oder so eine Art One-Stop-Shop, wenn ein Studierender eine Idee hat, die er vielleicht gründen will oder umsetzen will, dass er weiß, mit wem bespreche ich die jetzt oder wo sollte ich denn damit hingehen?
Und da wollen wir, das ist jetzt auch so, unser Gründungszentrum Highest kennt bei weitem noch nicht jeder Student hier an der Uni, aber das stärker zu etablieren, zu wissen, ah wenn du eine Idee hast …
Natürlich hat sich unser Präsidium Gründungsförderung auch als Strategie auf die Fahnen geschrieben.
Aber die rufen vielleicht nicht gleich im Präsidium an, sondern sollen dann wissen, ich kann zu Highest gehen und es ist auch leicht möglich und ich kriege da einen Termin oder ich schaue mal bei so einem Gründerstammtisch vorbei.
Wie heißt das genau?
Highest, also so wie das höchste im Englischen.
Ah Highest, verstehe.
Genau und das ist eine Home of Innovation Growth and Entrepreneurship.
Daraus eine Abkürzung zusammengesetzt und so haben wir das dann gelabelt sozusagen unser Gründungszentrum.
Wenn ich jetzt konkret beschließe, okay jetzt habe ich hier eine super Idee, weil ich habe mich sagen wir mal irgendeinem neuen technologischen Durchbruch zugewendet – jetzt erfinde ich mal was – Nanotechnologie, irgendwie Beschichtung von Werkzeugmaschinen, hat keiner auf dem Markt etc. und man hat so das Gefühl, da gibt es jetzt für das, womit ich mich jetzt hier ein Jahr lang intensiv beschäftigt habe ohnehin kein Unternehmen und das einzige, was es dann doch gibt, finde ich langweilig.
Was macht man denn dann und was hat man denn dann für Möglichkeiten, entweder aus dem Studium heraus, also während des Studiums oder in einem Anschluss jetzt hier.
Also was für Möglichkeiten bieten sich denn konkret, die ich jetzt nutzen müsste?
Gut, also die erste Frage ist glaube ich immer, hat man das alleine gemacht oder hat man zusammengearbeitet?
Noch einen Studentenkollegen genau.
Also zunächst würde ich mal selbst recherchieren, gibt es das noch nicht irgendwo anders?
Habe ich schon gemacht, gibt es nicht.
Ist das vielleicht doch …
Oder ist sagen wir mal …
Das ist immer gefährlich, das sage ich immer meinen Studierenden, das ist ja nur ein Zitat von dem Venture Capitalist, either you don’t know, how to use google or there ist no market.
Na gut, aber kann ja auch sein, dass man feststellt, okay da gibt es so 2-3 andere Startups, die sich halt in diesem Bereich bewegen und die das ähnlich sehen.
Ja, gibt es auch, ist ein reeller Fall auch, der hier immer wieder vorkommt.
Viele sagen dann, ich möchte das auch gründen, ich möchte das vorantreiben.
Machen es in der Regel oft nebenher neben dem Studium.
Manchmal merkt dann einer, entweder das Studium ist eh nicht so seins oder er macht vielleicht den Bachelorabschluss fertig und dann den Master erst mal nicht weiter.
Weil er sagt, er widmet sich erst mal dem Vorantreiben der Idee.
Was sich dann immer anbietet ist, wirklich zu unserem Gründungszentrum zu gehen, in die Gründungsberatung.
Weil wir hier auch ein Konzept entwickelt haben, das konkret dann mit den Gründern bespricht, was sie von der Idee halten.
Die müssen dann auch genau durchgehen, gibt es das wirklich noch nicht?
Wenn ja, wo gibt es das, in welcher Form, wie möchte ich das umsetzen?
Auch quasi selbst dann sich klarmachen, will ich das nebenbei vorantreiben oder möchte ich das hauptberuflich machen?
Was sind die Vor- und Nachteile von beiden Optionen?
Was auch damit zusammenhängt, wie sehe ich mein Leben in 5-10 Jahren.
Will ich da vielleicht ein sicheres Einkommen haben, weil ich schon zwei Kinder und Familie habe und die auch irgendwie durchbringen muss und nicht 80 Stunden die Woche arbeiten möchte an meiner Gründungsidee und nicht weiß, ob die je floriert.
All das sind da so Sachen, wo es auch ganz gut ist, mal mit einem Berater darauf zu blicken.
Ich sage es, weil unser Gründungszentrum bietet dieses Anlaufstelle, bietet die auch kostenfrei.
Aber es ist immer eine gute Möglichkeit das durchzusprechen mit einer externen Partei.
Weil jemand einen anderen Blickwinkel drauf wirft, vielleicht Fragen stellt, die man sich selbst so noch nicht gestellt hat.
Und es soll nicht unbedingt die Oma sein, die eh schon ihr ganzes Erspartes in die Idee gesteckt hat, weil sie an den Enkel oder die Enkelin glaubt, sondern die ist natürlich vielleicht voreingenommen.
Jemanden der mit kritischen Fragen rangeht oder eine möglichst neutrale Position hat.
Oder sich Beratung holen mit anderen Parteien, sich auch vielleicht bewerben.
Es gibt zahlreiche Gründungswettbewerbe, auch hier bekommt man Feedback.
Sich das einzuholen ist immer wichtig.
Und jetzt abgesehen vom Gründungsprozess selbst, dass ich sage, ich versuche Anlaufstellen, die mir Hilfestellung geben bei dem Vorantreiben meiner Geschäftsidee, die mir hier helfen, ist es immer auch wichtig und eins der wesentlichen Sachen, dass man zuerst versucht was ich da vorantreiben will, gibt es dafür einen Markt?
Also gibt es potenzielle Kunden oder Nutzer, die das brauchen und die auch bereit dafür sind, Geld zu zahlen.
So dass ich vielleicht irgendwann …
Woher weiß man das?
Ja indem man mit potenziellen Kunden spricht und indem man sagt, okay das ist jetzt eine Entwicklung, die habe ich gemacht, für wen könnte die interessant sein?
Und das so frühzeitig wie möglich zu machen ist unter anderem deshalb entscheidend, weil ganz oft und gerade im universitären Bereich und vielleicht auch sehr häufig bei Wissenschaftlern tüfteln die an den ausgefeiltesten Perfektionierungen ihrer Entwicklung, die aber vielleicht ein Kunde erstens vielleicht gar nicht braucht, vielleicht auch gar nicht sieht, oder vielleicht weil es das nanomillionste Verfeinerung der mikroskopischen Darstellung ist, sagt, das brauche ich auch gar nicht.
Weil mit der, die derzeit zehnmal schlechter ist, mit der komme ich auch schon gut zurecht.
Oder vielleicht auch einfach noch nicht versteht.
Auch das, natürlich braucht es vielleicht auch … vielleicht ist es eine Entwicklung, die auch erst in 10 Jahren bahnbrechend sein wird.
Dann ist die Frage, ob man das überdauern kann, ob es jeder erkennt, aber dennoch …
Aber wie sagte Henry Ford so schön, wenn ich meine Kunden gefragt hätte, dann hätten sie gesagt, schnellere Pferde.
Schnellere Pferde genau.
Dem muss man sich sozusagen auch ein bisschen Stück weit auch drüber hinaus setzen.
Exakt hier eine Vision zu haben und auch einen Weitblick ist sehr wichtig.
Aber sobald man sagt, das ist eine Anwendung, wo ich auch finde, oder es weiß da draußen vielleicht noch niemand, dass er da braucht, aber wenn ich es ihm vor die Nase setze und sage, jetzt benutz das mal oder du willst von A nach B kommen, hier ist aber kein Pferd, sondern was anderes, nutz das mal.
Dann sagt der vielleicht ja, aber ich kann da noch nicht gut einsteigen, weil das ist viel zu hoch die Treppe, dass ich da hochkomme.
Oder wie auch immer, die Räder das federt ja noch gar nicht genug, ich hätte gerne, dass es mich nicht bei jedem Steinschlag durchschüttelt, kann man da nicht was einbauen?
Und so kriegt man dann zumindest eine Rückmeldung von der bahnbrechenden Neuheit, die man entwickelt hat als Geschäftsidee, was möchte denn der Kunde jetzt tatsächlich?
Oder in welche Richtung sollte ich es weiterentwickeln.
Und wenn man nicht nur mit einem Kunden redet, sondern mit einer größeren Bandbreite, bekommt man da schon ein Gespür dafür, ah jetzt sagen mir von den 20 Leuten 19 alle was in die Richtung, hätte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt dahin entwickelt, aber werde ich dann vielleicht doch mal machen.
Klingt jetzt aber schon wieder so ein bisschen zurückhaltend.
Ich meine wenn ich mich so voll mal in dieses Gründungsmoment reinsetze, dann muss man ja auch ein bisschen die Kraft haben, das was die anderen sagen auch ein Stück weit zu ignorieren.
Weil wenn die alle schon meiner Meinung wären, dann hätten sie ja vielleicht selber schon in diesem Bereich Aktivitäten entwickelt.
Ja. Bin ich völlig bei Ihnen. Wenn es darum geht zu sagen, ich möchte was visionäres voranbringen.
Aber sobald ich mal eine Art Prototyp habe oder eine Grundlage der Entwicklung, dann mit potenziellen Nutzern zu sprechen, ist schon entscheidend.
Weil ganz häufig ist es bei Gründungen, das zeigen auch Forschungsergebnisse, dass diese Kundennähe oder die Bereitschaft sozusagen das Produkt anzubieten für das, was der Kunde auch wertschätzt, wofür er auch vielleicht am Ende bereit ist, wirklich Geld zu zahlen, dass das sehr sehr gering ausgeprägt ist.
Und ich glaube auch, dass das, wenn wir nochmal auf unsere Kultur in Deutschland zu sprechen kommen, auch was ist, wo wir an uns arbeiten können, weil diese technische Perfektionierung, das haben wir auch historisch gesehen sehr sehr gut drauf, dann aber zu sagen, ich gehe her, wie es oft in den USA der Fall ist und sage einfach mal, was braucht mein Kunde eigentlich?
Oder wie es jetzt von diesen Social Network oder auch den E-Commerce Unternehmen zur Exessivität betreiben, dass die schon was nutzt der Kunde, was ist für den bequem, wann kriegt der sein Produkt geliefert, wie schnell?
Er muss vielleicht nichts zusätzlich zahlen und trotzdem hat er folgende Dinge on top.
Die funktioniert aber noch nicht perfekt, der hat es vielleicht, obwohl ich versichert habe, er kriegt es noch am selben Tag, doch erst einen Tag später bekommen.
10% der Fälle, dann würden wir das in der Tendenz her in Deutschland eher nie veröffentlichen oder noch gar nicht umsetzen, sondern erst wenn vielleicht 1% es nicht am gleichen Tag bekommt, sondern erst einen Tag später.
Und in den USA probiert man es erst mal aus, merkt dann, ach aber viele sind gar nicht böse, wenn sie es da noch gar nicht haben, das müssen wir gar nicht unbedingt ausbauen als Feature.
Der Stifterverband nimmt sich ja des Gründungsthemas auch an durch das Gründungsradar, das kennen Sie ja sicherlich.
Was schon mal auch versucht, so ein bisschen die Qualität der Unterstützung, ich glaube auch teilweise der Forschung, zu quantifizieren und vergleichbar zu machen.
Ist das ein hilfreiches Instrument für das Thema?
Ja auf jeden Fall.
Also da wird ja beleuchtet auch in der deutschen Hochschullandschaft, wie gut sind hier die Gründungsaktivitäten in unterschiedlichen Teilbereichen umgesetzt und auch ausgebaut?
Und es ist ja schon sehr sehr interessant dahingehend, dass unterschiedliche Stellhebel betrachtet werden.
Also wie gut ist beispielsweise die Strategie umgesetzt in der Universität, dass Gründungen gefördert werden?
Wie gut ist beispielsweise die finanzielle Ausstattung, was gibt es hier auch für eine Heterogenität innerhalb von deutschen Hochschulen?
Was setzen die denn auch um?
Also hat vielleicht eine Hochschule sehr sehr wenig finanzielle Mittel zur Verfügung, ist aber trotzdem super stark an der Anzahl an Ausgründungen, die aus der Hochschule hervorgehen.
Und das liefert schon interessante Indikatoren.
Erstens was hier möglich ist, auch im Vergleich der Hochschulen untereinander, was haben andere, was haben wir?
Auch eine Art Messbarkeit.
Und hier zeigt sich ja zum einen auch, dass beispielsweise viele der Universitäten, die ausgewählt wurden, also eine dieser Exist-4 geförderten Gründerhochschulen, dass die sehr starke Aktivitäten haben.
Jetzt müsste man das natürlich genauer untersuchen als einzelnes Förderprogramm.
Aber was einen Indikator zumindest liefert, dass diese öffentlich vom Ministerium geförderte Initiative doch auch Früchte trägt.
Darüber hinaus gibt es dann gewisse Maßzahlen und Indikatoren, die ja auch angeben, wie wird diese Gründungsförderung gelebt und umgesetzt in den Universitäten?
Also ganz wichtig ist hier häufig genannt, dass es auch in der Hochschulzeitung verankert ist.
Das kann aber immer noch auf vielfältige Art und Weise geschehen.
Das kann in einem Programm stehen, das kann an zentraler Stelle, gleich wenn man die Hauptseite der Homepage ansurft, gleich hier irgendwo verankert sein.
Es kann auch jemand zuständigen explizit in der Hochschulleitung geben, der mit dem Thema vertraut ist.
Was natürlich auch nochmal die Verbindlichkeit fördert in der Regel.
Ja und ganz unterschiedliche Aktivitäten.
Es ist hier auch sehr interessant, und deswegen …
Oder ein wesentliches Element, wo ich immer glaube, was entscheidend sein kann, jetzt in unterschiedlichen Settings sind ja die Anreizstrukturen, in denen wir tätig sind.
Und hier ist zum Beispiel sehr oft an Universitäten in den Anreizstrukturen, die auch Institutsleiter, Professoren oder wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiter haben, die Forschung oft hochgehalten.
Es ist selten der Fall, dass es wirklich einen Anreiz gibt.
Jetzt in unterschiedlicher Hinsicht.
Dass jemand sagt als Professor oder wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter, mir ist auch dran gelegen, ich habe einen Anreiz, Gründungen aus meinem Institut oder aus meinem Fachbereich hervorzubringen.
Und solche Anreizstrukturen zu schaffen ist nicht einfach.
Aber wenn man auch diesen Gründungsradar anschaut, gibt es doch unterschiedliche Maßnahmen, die anscheinend praktiziert werden.
Und das kann jetzt sein, dass es auch finanzielle Anreize für den einzelnen Forscher gibt.
Dass es eher ich sage mal kreative Möglichkeiten sind, wie dass man auch eine Art …
Man hat ja oft an der Universität, auch wenn man spezielle Forschungsvorhaben hat, beispielsweise ein Forschungsfreisemester, wo man in dem Semester keine Lehre erbringen muss, aber sich explizit dann für das Voranbringen des Forschungsvorhabens einsetzt.
Und was ähnliches könnte es beispielsweise auch umgesetzt kriegen, wenn man sagt, man macht das eben für eine Ausgründung, die man vorantreiben möchte und hat deshalb eine Reduzierung der Lehrbelastung.
Also für eine eigene Ausgründung?
Genau zum Beispiel. Oder auch finanzielle Anreizstrukturen, dass man sagt, man bekommt eine Erhöhung auch.
Es gibt ja Budgets, die zugewiesen werden, wird es da berücksichtigt oder ist das überhaupt nicht erfasst?
Und in vielen Systemen ist es überhaupt nicht erfasst, dass Institute als Ziel haben, Gründungen hervorzubringen und warum sollten die sich dann auch in der Hinsicht engagieren?
Und das ist glaube ich was, wo man sehr viel auch tun könnte.
Wo glaube ich noch nicht genug getan wird und wo man auch unterschiedliche Modelle, also best practise auch mal genauer als eigene Hochschule unter die Lupe nehmen kann und schauen kann, kann man das nicht umsetzen?
Und das Radar liefert sozusagen Material für eine Vergleichbarkeit und vielleicht auch für neue Ansätze an anderen Standorten, die ja sicherlich auch alle von unterschiedlichen Grundlagen ausgehen.
Mit anderen Studiengängen aufgestellt sind, andere Förderungsoptionen haben in ihren Ländern etc.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, hier wird ja auch sehr detailliert unterschieden zwischen den Bereichen, wie wir sie im Prinzip auch schon aufgeschlüsselt haben, wenngleich auch nicht unbedingt so benannt.
Also es wird von einer Sensibilisierung gesprochen.
Also welche Motivation bringt man überhaupt erst mal ins Feld dann eben über die konkrete Unterstützung und dann wird auch noch betrachtet, wie die konkreten Aktivitäten denn aussehen.
Und was letzten Endes auch an den Universitäten herausfällt.
Ja Frau Bock, Gründungsmanagement ist ein weiteres Metathema.
Ich finde das immer ganz interessant, wenn so Studiengänge quasi Fachgebiete mit Angeboten bekommen, die irgendwie gar nicht dazu passen, aber dann doch eben doch.
Anderes Extrem, was wir hier auch schon behandelt haben, ist so, zum Beispiel Wissenschaftshistorie.
Dass man sozusagen einfach auch mal mehr lernt über das, wie hat sich denn Wissenschaft überhaupt so entwickelt über die Jahrhunderte auch.
Woraus man eben sehr viel ziehen kann für die grundlegende Arbeit.
Und hier haben wir so ein anderes Extrem, wo man sagt, okay ja Wissenschaft für sich, Forschung, Lehre, alles schön und gut, aber es gibt halt auch noch eine wirtschaftliche Realität, die wird euch früher oder später ohnehin betreffen, wir legen jetzt hier mal so ein Besteck an den Tisch, kannst ja mal gucken, wie du damit klarkommst.
Wir bieten auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit einerseits eben Handlungsoptionen zu erkennen vielleicht, die dann eben auf dem Tisch liegen.
Oder eben am Ende auch ein neues Forschungsfeld, was einem vielleicht auch selber am Herzen liegt, um das dann zu verfolgen.
Insofern bedanke ich mich schön für das Gespräch.
Ich danke auch Herr Pritlove.
Und vielen Dank an alle wieder hier bei Forschergeist.
Wir machen bald weiter, ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.